- You know what, let's just let 'em go.
(audience laughing)
- Just let 'em walk around.
- Enjoy yourselves.
Just go, Just go!
- Wait, they can't hurt themselves, right,
if they come off of the-?
Don't all cat's land on your
feet or their feet? Okay.
- No, no. What are you talking about?
- No, I've heard this,
if a cat falls or
something, they always land
on their feet.
- So the cat falls,
they land on their feet.
- Oh my God, it's on the back.
I'm a mom, I'm a mom, you gotta get it,
you gotta get it, you gotta get it!
- It's gonna be fine.
- Come here!
- This is how they learn,
- Come here.
- This is how they learn.
- Oh, I've gotta get you.
I've gotta get you!
- Anyway, I see you guys
are very excited about my films.
- Oh my God! (laughing)
(audience applauding)
The poor kitty.
- I mean, look at this!
Look how TV ready they are.
- (laughing) They just need some catnip
and a commercial.
- Put an album cover
right here just like.
(audience applauding)
- All right, no, seriously though!
- Have you ever seen?
- They're set up.
They're set up.
- This guy better
fall in line, all right, go over there.
- Oh! You are a crawler.
- That's good.
- Oh, you're going all the way around.
So about your films
- Uhuh?
- What? You're crazy!
I don't want you to die man, okay.
So about your films--
- I don't know.
- "Becky" and "Happily".
- "Becky" and "Happily", yes.
- Yes, "Becky" is made by
me and a wonderful
actress named Lulu Wilson,
and Kevin James.
(audience applauding)
- Right on.
- It is definitely not a comedy,
and then the other one's called "Happily",
directed by a guy named
Ben David Grabinski,
and it's me and a wonderful
actor named Kerry Bishé
and Stephen Root, who
you've seen on "Barry"
and a thousand other
things, like "NewsRadio",
but no one's listened
to a thing I've said.
(audience laughing)
It doesn't matter.
- 'Cause all the cats are here.
- Let's just move onto the red
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Let's see what happens,
it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, take a sip.
Oh, wait, that's mine.
- That's yours, wait.
- Ya, no no no, just kidding.
- (laughs) Oh my god! You are hilarious!
- That's fine.
- Okay! Let's see the legs.
- That's in April, I know
you'll all go to the film
festival and you're gunna love it.
- (laughs) Swig!
- Oh it's fine, it's fine! It's a cat!
- Wait, okay so wait, Joel so Card Sharks,
Card Sharks is back, do
you like being a game host?
Is it fun?
- What is a game host?
- A game host, you're
hosting a game - I think the
definition is in the name!
- I think it's game show,
it's a game show host.
- Game show host!
- We give away cats, and-
- Please don't die!
- This is gunna go great, you
can win, look, yeah, you can
win a lot of money-
- Yeah
- I can totally get you on the show-
- Yeah okay
- But if you think about it
Kelly, nobody is listening
to a thing we have said,
in the last few minutes...
- (laughs)